Disney has officially announced that it
will be delaying the release of its much
mocked cartoonishly Li liveaction remake
of Snow White for a comparison here is
Disney's new Snow White you said you
were bringing a Modern Edge to it on
stage what do you mean by that I just
mean that it's no longer
1937 and we absolutely wrote a snow
white that is she's not going to be
saved by the prince she's not going to
be saved by The Prince and she's not
going to be dreaming about true love
she's dreaming about becoming the leader
she knows she can be sounds great here's
our Snow White by 2030 it's predicted
that 45% of women will be unmarried and
childless and why do you think that is
well it's because we've been told that
you know men are trash and that our
career is the only thing that matters
and that marriage and children will
inhibit that which is unnatural that is
biologically unnatural for women that
does sound great that's I mean what's
happening is really bad but the fact
that our Snow White realizes that that's
a problem and the girls actually do want
a prince and they do want like normal
stuff that's a good sign